this is our real thoughts on pixels
surprisingly it's not that different
from the review
um but it I think over time you got to
hate it even more than I hated it more
when we were doing the review I started
hating it more as I was really like
looking at what we were saying about it
but I still you know there's been a
bunch of reviews going around I won't
name names but some of them have gone
viral and declaring uh is the worst
thing ever and oh my god it's so cynical
is just trying to catch an 80s nostalgia
this may be the most desperate saddest
example of it and I really like pixels
cuz it's not a good movie it's not even
aiming remotely resembling a good movie
it's a bad movie but I'm like thinking
of all the things like Terminator
Genisys Smurfs Garfield and like really
pixels is the one we're going to flip
our shit over and be like even that's it
the final straw like the final straw has
been years ago like this I it's not even
enough of a trainwreck for me to get
that worked up over it was just shocking
and how nothing it was just I think
that's why I getting to N I think that's
why people were getting as angry as
their word because I mean this is like
not only does a Nancy our movie this is
110 million dollar Adam Sandler movie at
supposed to be his big budget action
film that still relies on just the
unfunniest parts of Adam Sandler's
comedy which am Stan where's comedy can
be very funny and very inventive and and
so much fun yeah it's he's got some rage
involved it's like some of the better
ones I have seen ahead I have seen Zohan
now and I don't think I liked as much as
you did but I'm not so it was so ok oh
my god gets very racially insensitive
don't get me wrong every party that I'm
like okay this is really funny didn't
like is it you but I like happy gilmore
I like wedding wedding singer um and
there tends to be an element of rage
where he gets unhinged somewhere in the
movie um I like to punch drunk love uh
if a penny for his AIDS
he's pretty even-tempered I thought that
he was pretty even-tempered there but
there tends to be something and then
this one it was almost like a non
performance yeah Harris no that's the
fun I think there's no goofy voice
there's one I think there was one line
one line Murray shut up there - goofy
voice and that was it I was like wow
this really just there was I can't even
yell and scream about how Oh Adam
Sandler is being obnoxious it's it's
almost just like he didn't even show up
yeah I've never been in an Adam Sandler
film or just like Christ where you do a
goofy voice just so something's
happening well and he can be I am me the
thing whenever people think they think
I'm like yeah but oh wow the just the
fart jokes and stuff but he can be so I
mean not just charming but like Will
Smith insanely charming not just in real
life but in these movies he can be so
huggable I'm not gonna go Wilson
but I mean he's well okay when I work
whenever people talk about what we're
gonna do a little too much credit there
um but this why I hate filming in this
room work um one she just put it on
automatic because then we're just like
shadows this is mrs. um but stupid
modern technology anyway it nah but but
yeah the point is it is somewhere in
between this which is just enough for
minh sitter ly he sat there just read
his lines and left and as some like
water boy a little or a fucking little
Mickey which I still haven't forgiven
you for dragging me to that back no
should you uh yeah I I had seen it yet
to be fair we are both discussed
somewhere is somewhere in between those
two is a pretty good Adam Sandler
performance I like that this is an in he
just doesn't do anything yeah I think
because like that there's something to I
think with this movie they kind of
wanted like another kind of Ghostbusters
ish thing and so they have this newly to
be no murder no but that's why I think
they're kind of banking out they want
him to kind of be like Bill Murray uh
you know where he's like kind of funny
but he's also kind of like the everyman
and stuff like that so we don't want the
goofy voice we can't want something like
Ghostbusters but in Oz it know to be
fair I think he could pull that off okay
but this type
humor that they're doing where they're
still relying on all these troves in
these cliches and just non humour health
until script makes no sense I mean it
they're the whole big thing not the
thing is that he just keeps saying to
the zoo or your kind of snobby or
somebody snobby and I'm like from the
reviewers like at the end of every shot
I just heard to tear when I go stop and
like that is like the running thing like
oh she's snobby like and I'm like
endearing and yet like occasionally she
will look at him like you know what his
charm starting to work at me every
called me a snob for the 700th time you
know um the whole like so many jokes
here's part of the problem there's so
many jokes where it's all setup and no
pail yeah that's a thing like a wrap
yeah I was the same way I was like cuz
I'm like it's it's video games Adam
Sandler I'm like I'm ready to laugh all
that it was like all set up all set up
to a joke or punchline and then nothing
happens it's when I saw oh I guess the
joke happened and we missed when I saw
Brian Cox was in this movie I got really
excited then when I saw he's like this
general guy had the military I got even
more excited it's like shit they're just
doing the same phoned-in bullcrap where
I'm just gonna make you look bad and I
was very aware of it or not it yeah it
the whole scene in the beginning where
he leaves and he gets called to the
White House because Kevin James is the
president yes shocked that if that is
off why I even for a sailor we look we
look at each other we're just like no no
that can't be right that's a joke right
that's not I'm like oh they're really
doing this okay um guys to Turkey all
right I'm just and they do nothing with
the fact that he's president it's also
get literally was again a setup with no
payoff they had that whole setup about
oh it's tough in my job on I gotta wear
a suit every day no no matter what I do
people to like me this is like do a full
reveal shot and there's the Secret
Service guess he's the president's like
they did something one
little Joker's I even that good okay
just reveal they did it just for that
fucking reveal um but Peter Dinklage who
is just like right now on fucking fire
with the choices he's making and how
charismatic and funny he is I don't know
what's going in this move but not but
like a lot of people in salmon movies
it's like you bring in these really good
people and I I'm sure that's just like
okay this Sandler guy is pretty popular
I think with the kids and stuff like
that so let's kinda try it whatever and
like there's no direction there's no
thoughts on anything or maybe it was
funny on set but yeah for the theater I
mean it's just these long pauses of
silence like honey you're supposed to
laugh here and just like I'm gonna do
some sort of accent you're not gonna I
what exit was that what were you doing
we even dude look us like say another
four year then we turn in an American
how we say you know it's like oh man
yeah talk about an epic Dinklage yeah
well here's a big it's like well at
least it's good that he's reminded us
that he can be in shit again if he needs
to yeah but he like sometimes it's like
he's it's like he's human after all
yeah could be I forget before Game of
Thrones you know in Narnia and somebody
it was a trap yeah it wasn't always
perfect yeah okay dig with my school's
usually good bombs but he's been so good
lately that's like okay good now you're
human okay yeah it so he was he was
terrible in this um it isn't the worst
no I think people are just finally fed
up because like like I said the review
they see this talent and they want to
like Sam when they hear he's a nice
great guy and I I totally believe them
and he seems like a really nice great
guy he can be reasonably personal
vendetta against Adam Sandler the person
know if the professional careers I hate
just yeah but it's like I want to see
this great comedy against he never
really got you know the plot always from
day one were recycled they were terrible
bloody one he was funny if he could
bring this county after I kind of liked
him this whole thing was the kid like
that was about that was about it I was
like
his performance seems legitimate at
least with us art except for an
inexplicable scene where he's getting
pixelize and he's smiling and I'm like
what some people some people especially
kids I find have a thing where when
they're supposed to be like crying they
do like a little smile or something like
do a tic - I agree and say don't do that
- you know trying again
um but yeah the weird thing is like
watching the beginning of this movie I
was more interested in what was going on
with these kids characters at the arcade
competition because the than anything
with them as adults those kids were kind
of interesting and it got me thinking
I'm like this movie was done completely
wrong who the fuck wants to see a grown
up Adam Sandler and some you know and
Kevin James and the snowman from
freaking frozen playing video games
giant video games as adults this could
have been a perfect kids movie no I
think you look generally you could have
them be a ticket you could have had them
be deities a you could you could have
happened in the 80s come here than be
kids it would be kind of a spoof of
those Japanese monster films where
there's always some child that somehow
knows how to solve you can don't like
super a kind that makes a you don't make
it more scary you make it more and I'm
just look at this like this could have
been a perfectly fine kids film but the
fact that they're using adults just
completely kills the idea yeah no I
agree and the fact they try to make it
Adam Sandler movie instead of you know a
more recent kind of comedy as this is
just committed completely wrong director
I don't know how Chris Columbus got
attached to this but I think they were
hoping because like you know gremlins
and stuff like that that'd be something
if this was anywhere near as dark as
gremlins or is interesting that would
have been fine but that would have been
interesting I could dark like a really
dark room like pac-man eating the guy's
hand it's like that's a good start
that's kind of us and either physically
here's the thing uh but the action
scenes in this film suck they're
confusing you can't make out really
what's going on they it really like I
know we say this about Michael Bay films
but at least Michael Bay films whatever
supposed to be going on while that
camera is shaking like mad it's somehow
May
cents in there like i feel like--okay in
this universe something's going on he's
just shaking the camera this one the
camera isn't even always moving around
but it's literally like they just threw
a bunch of effects together randomly
like that finale in Washington DC there
was so much shit going on a month I
don't know what to look at tell me what
to lookin cuz there was so much shit
going on I couldn't make it out it's
like there's 40 things here here here
and here and most of the action was not
that interesting I I don't think Chris
Columbus is a good action director I
don't know why you would get somebody
like him to do this like me I think I'm
aiming for a really well and
Ghostbusters I've arrived it wasn't
enacted I think everything was trying to
recreate those monsters isn't really an
action film no no I
I agree but again I'm trying to say why
choose him I think because closest thing
I could think of that Chris Columbus
would have done like this would have
been maybe Harry Potter hmm but again
that's not really a yeah the third
Potter films the best the two just
passed by in cuteness but I don't
remember it for its action yeah like if
I think of the action set-pieces of the
Potter films they tend to be from the
later movies did so yeah I don't
and even gremlins I wouldn't put down as
an action film it's all he wrote it you
did directly yeah he didn't direct it so
it that was Joe tanta Joe Dante should
have done this movie then he hasn't done
that many huge big is just waste away
hey you know I think this would have
been more up his alley though than Chris
Columbus and then here's the big things
he did films like explores he's done
films with childhood nostalgia he's mad
you know he's done things with special
effects even if I didn't love them the
love dolly tunes back in action is not a
good movie but it's much closer than
Space Jam the cantering with a woman
well and small soldiers I don't think is
a good movie but he knew how to work
with the special effects are could least
tell kind of what was going up yeah um
this one yeah I don't know Justin I
think what they were trying to do - I
think Columbus I think Chris Columbus
was like everybody else in this room
just wasted I think what they were
trying to do too is that as one of the
reviews was saying like they're trying
to make Sam we've look like a geek kind
of like today's geek that can be kind of
popular with like superhero movies and
says he doesn't gig squad kinda yep
yeah they throw the geeks buzz it's like
a link he just looks like that random
dude you don't want to talk to who's
installing your tell him and then again
you then creepily in her like what it's
just very clear they don't understand
kind of like that geek culture at least
the entertaining geek culture and then
you try to throw in yeah the snow man
from frozen who were just trying to make
even more pathetic and more creepy which
I mean right now it's like there are so
many pathetic weird creepy internet
trolls and stuff like that that it's
like just take your pick choose anything
it's like I don't know what this is what
this guy I don't know hated but there's
so many funny
totally weird pathetic people out there
that you can easily make fun of this
just you're not even making fun of them
I don't know what they're trying to do
here with this guy it's like I think
they're trying to be those pathetic
people but like I just I guess rain eyes
it um I think a lot of this is like
they're thinking like they're sort of
acknowledging and doing a parody of this
geek culture but it's like they've never
seen today's geek culture it's not
because it's about 80's games ah so so
instead of setting it in the 80s which
would have made some fucking sense it's
like we're gonna set it now and
apparently there's only three people in
the universe he's never played an
eighties game which I and as we pointed
on the review I remember sitting there
as he grabs the gun is firing at the
Senate me that I'm like in what universe
I know people like whoa if you play
didn't get to hear gay queer name right
not like Oz and I'm not like this you
don't automatically know how to use
bazookas and laser guns and maybe if he
had been playing duck hunt this whole
time but we didn't see that yeah you
know or that freakin Nintendo bazooka or
whatever it so I'm like how does this
translate for mashing buttons to
grabbing a gun and having impeccable egg
or driving and running around these
out-of-shape guys running around yeah I
you know or driving a car or racing
which brings us to the other thing I
mean this drove me fucking insane like
cuz they make this huge thing that Peter
Dinklage's character cheats
oh you cheated and the aliens are all
upset Oh
Gina and how the help you actually see
over the screen like your heart is not
working then it's like I used a new coat
where would it be the cheat code in the
car never explained how can that work in
real life as never yeah how does it
worked in your life that knowing the
cheat code somehow makes your car magic
like it's being run by wizard how does
that how that was never explained like
at least there was some sense of physics
that these aliens have created these
pixel things and they're attacking just
like an Independence Day the ships
attack fucking Jeff Goldblum didn't say
oh I'm gonna enter a cheat code and make
my Volkswagen Beetle like zip across
then it doesn't work that way um but and
here's something I would have forgiven
that I would have forgiven that if it
weren't for the fucking ending and I was
the one who definitely like was like you
need to put this in here when he tosses
the hammer because I'm like these aliens
were so pissed off that they cheated
sewing okay there's a moral never gene
so how does Adam Sandler win the day by
doing the move in Donkey Kong that you
can't fucking do you can't just throw a
hammer and take out Donkey Kong so I
cheated so the whole point of that it
was just absolutely pointless you just
cheated away the victory somehow it
blows up the alien mothership I don't
know how it's what were these aliens
deals anyway like they never never seen
aliens yeah which I wouldn't even mind
if the geek kind of cool reason or
something but it's like no and then we
never communicate we never find out
anything really about them except that
they misinterpret this message and you
know again if it was well come on you
just want to see Adam Sandler go up
against videogame characters and stuff I
would have loved that movie I love love
they did like the lego movie where
they're just making it up and it was
ambitious and was funny and it didn't
you know logic be damned we're just
having fun but then are you doing it you
didn't even know you do
to have the corny romance you had to
have the bully you have to have all
these peoples are not funny oh my gosh
did you yet what I mean though that at
least at least Jurassic world spent all
of like two minutes on that stupid
romance and you were kind of done like
look at how long talk with him and her
at the party just goes on forever well
my health we know you're gonna get
together long this lasts it kept going
on in on the who taught you I hate you
at the very all your hopes like I
thought I love you though like hey how
about instead of let's just put in a
two-second romance how about we just if
we're gonna do a romance let's do it
good I don't think that's an excuse for
Jurassic Walker
no but it's a lot easier to get to and
to get through and to forgive than
sitting through the romance and
something like this I swear to God I
said you already 40 fucking minutes
that's like saying you want to punch to
the face or a kick to the nuts well I
guess I punch the face then I'll punch
to the face is good no it's still bad
last really good romance you've seen in
a blockbuster film lately and well now I
can't go through all like the
blockbuster films and stuff um my point
exactly
so much everyone's like most here
generally in a blockbuster movie going
to get smacked around somehow yes I will
take the slap in the face over the giant
knee to the groin the testicular killing
need to the groin any day and Jurassic
world was a slap in the face this was a
need to the fucking cry I don't want to
be slapped so I am you know crazy me
making it and don't go and move hey yeah
maybe a movies we should get slapped
that don't go then don't go see movies
cuz it's gonna yeah your way makes a lot
more sense no I'm just saying it's gonna
happen they're not list they're they're
not listening to us so it's gonna happen
no I will I will at least appreciate
it's like no no I'm fine I have
Stockholm Syndrome I am identifying with
my fucking captors and you know a
Jurassic world
I have Stockholm Syndrome and when I
just got slapped in the faces of getting
need into the groin or having electrodes
like shoved into my testicles or what
I'll take
and I will say thank you sir that's what
a salmon romance now does to me but um
but no I think we've seen Sandler Phil's
are just Sandler products like master in
disguise and the other happy mass and
bullshit oh ha that's much worse well
that's what killed me I did that because
everybody's flipping out about this and
every and everybody's like right here
keep me this booth could be terrible and
I was like well I don't know video games
I like so Chris Columbus room I'm like
Chris Columbus is Congress come on mrs.
hit MS but I mean he's done some good
stuff I was so sampler so we're kind of
obey appear danger look but here's the
thing and I'm just like I thought it was
just adam sailing was in it like
somebody just has no is happy Madison
then about two weeks before the film
came out I saw was a Happy Madison
productions like oh no that's like shit
I didn't realize you already shot yeah I
know BAM already shoot myself like I
just God um I've tried think it was
anything else about this okay I want CDs
it's not what you know what just you die
I'm monopolizing the conversation just
cuz I'll just gonna say I really I think
Sandler can still do good stuff and I
I'm hoping Hotel Transylvania to a good
um yeah okay cuz that that was a good
movie and I liked the original yeah I
think there's something to when and I
got that got really pan Hotel
Transylvania so I it's one of those
things like that let me let me be clear
that was not exactly a great workout but
buddy got pad and I'm like but it was
really was perfectly passable I would
that that to me is a great wise not I
know I do not that it's a b-movie and
that if you're grading it a through F
I'm like it's it's a BB - movie I think
it's perfectly fine no I was thought
what I was talking with um and I think
I've shared the story before but the
director of a crazy night saw the review
but it was still up and um and said and
Sheridan said I do really like this I I
acknowledge now you know it's the fault
of it but you know he also praised
something good stuff and he told me a
little bit about him saying he said that
he really does feel even though not all
the stuff is great that there is kind of
as bad
let's all just hate Adam Sandler because
we've gotten used to let's just hate
everything he fucking does and you know
to some extent there's a lot of stuff he
does it's just so painful so bad but
then another times with something like
Hotel Transylvania comes out and it's
like no like he's not always this will
be good but he's good in it and he does
a good job and when he boring just like
nobodies Adam Sandler so it can't be
good it's like I'm sorry are you going
with Mitchell's no this is the worst
this is the absolute most terrible awful
it's not even edible even I'm sorry
anybody who sits there and goes on and
on about how this is the one that this
is it it's not gonna get any worse than
this it's like Holly ugh a fail yeah
until Fantastic Four now that's the new
and everybody's dating at it's like
anybody who says that I don't trust it
yeah because I'm like I don't did your
luck in the bitch about something this
is an easy target it's it's an easy
target it's low-hanging fruit and I know
we've been sitting here bitching about
this movie but really when it's all said
and done I can't even it's just it's not
funny
and it just it exists that's all I can
say about it it is not the worst thing
ever made I've seen a thousand movies a
thousand times worse than this there are
movies that try to basically campaign in
our nostalgia way worse than this like
it is not have you seen the latest Jem
trailer yeah it's not I love when people
just like oh it's the most cynical
attempt by Hollywood to even attempt to
basically reach off on nostalgia like
this I'm like really really this is the
one did you just crawl out of a cave
like were you living in a cave for 20
years now like this is the one else and
so it's it's not even in the same
ballpark it's just simply a bad movie
it's a failed comedy it's like the best
way to compare it is Arnold
Schwarzenegger is jr. where you just sit
there and you're just like it just
doesn't leave an impression it's not
funny
you sit there you're like well somebody
thought this is gonna get a laugh it's
like Arnold Schwarzenegger isn't that
funny you know the guy who should be
hilarious normally in the same thing
with Sandler I would normally think
Sandler at least even if he's not funny
would be outrageous and he's not even
outrageous in this movie it's like the
most restricting
and Sandler performance I've seen in
years well that's what the reason I have
all the people asking me to do you know
hey Kiki do the colliculus reviewing
pixels um I wanted to address but hey it
was getting because again I mean going
back to nostalgia the the Adam Sandler
movies I mean that those are big fucking
hits and now it's like we have a similar
formula and we're sick of it so again
trying to take something of that past
and be like why didn't work then not now
I think it is because just nothing is
being added or furthered or gained to it
at all and it's relying on the worst
qualities of those films which I like a
lot of those films but there's a lot of
bad qualities as relying on dieting is
that the best qualities of he and his
team are writing formulaic 80s movies
that's what that's all this is like
whitter it is like Ghostbusters it is
like stripes it is like it is basically
a bunch of outsider nerd types who I
will never amount to emotion who are
mostly kind of a comp and everything but
are good at this one thing I mean the
Ghostbusters when you look at it I mean
the Dean was so V right he's like you're
not very good science but when it came
to busting ghosts they were good at this
one thing you know like army a darkness
evil led to ash is an idiot but he's
good at that one thing defeating
Deadites like you know just done all
over again and the thing is it's just
it's old now like it so unless you're
gonna be really fresh with it like I
knew something I liked happy gilmore and
it's the same kind of formula and yes I
still think it's funny but that was
years ago
no but on top of it there is a nice be
there is this energy there is this you
know calming to it that's still strange
and unexpected and can still make me
laugh even though I'm like yeah I know
this story or a sign you know oh my
precious is the same thing that's not a
good story by any means but I like these
- they are likable they're enjoyable and
they're funny and I think yeah just
somewhere along the line it's like you
can't it's like the the charisma of
Sandler here you know belongs in
something that's like you know a drama
or something like that doesn't
in this kind of google there is no
common email because you're relying on
all the notes I have my work I don't
even say you would work in a drama there
just wasn't it that was the weird thing
that just was no charisma
I can't even say oh he was obnoxious or
I have to send as he did there just was
nothing it's just like he just showed up
now I'm read my lines and yeah yeah you
know everyone saying the past few movies
are like of his have been like that and
I I don't know what's going on I don't
know if they're just bad choices or
something going on but I mean that this
is a guy that's got man talent and can
be so funny and everyone says it's just
such a nice person it's AI would love to
see him come back and do something
totally different totally new but
totally energized and totally passionate
and you know for it to succeed I would
love to see that ah and maybe maybe this
will be like kind of a wake-up call like
a tweet this is a lot of money we spent
on this and like that this ain't working
anymore we got to try something
different something new and we have to
really put in a lot of effort into
making it fresh and new and not just
relying on the old tricks so all I know
is it's it's not even worth getting that
worked up over like as we just kind of
do but I know what you're done I'm in
but I but I mean here's the thing we do
this for the review and to talk to
people and we get it all once but like
I'm not going to be sitting here fuming
over pixels yeah I'm not gonna like keep
me up at night I'm not gonna let I will
admit that we're trying to entertain you
guys as well a lot of you may think
we're not doing a very good job you know
so are a lot of you take it too
seriously so you know the idea is you
know we're trying to make it
entertaining and arguing and yes I
really do feel that way that there are
so many stupid decisions in this movie
and as I say them they sound bad but
I'll completely forget about this movie
right after we turn the camera off yeah
cuz I'd forgotten about it already and
like for a good two days now and it's
it's I'm not gonna sit here and go to
bed every big pixels of babies that my
child is raped and stabbed know if you
want to grieve it look a little bit
college humor like death of childhood or
something like that
it's just another one of those where
people complain no Michael Bay you know
destroyed by childhood initio someone
else like a world war ii survivor it's
just like I saw my parents killed in
front of me yes my child and they show
the real like people who had their
childhood destroyed my thing with that
that was a real problem Kath Jim we've
got transformers we've got turtles we've
had all these things III could get
something like so maybe Zelda maybe
Metroid oh I I grew up in the 80s I grew
up I was more of an Atari and an NES
person but how attached you have to be
the Donkey Kong impact man like outside
a fucking king of Kong how attached you
have to be real life is bricked by
childhood becomes addicted the point
back man I can't believe that Qbert like
it I I am those games were fun but they
really had their you couldn't get his
attach to it there was no real plot to
most of them Super Mario Brothers any
more of a bit sad those I really do
think it's cuz so much time and money
went into this movie there's such a
rehash of these formulas oh I have your
arguments about how it's like it's ruin
my childhood I'm like austenite it had
been dark aids I played NES games Super
Mario Brothers that stupid movie didn't
ruin my childhood I certainly bought
Super Mario World still and still play
it like it how attached to video games
are you particularly older video games
that I just can't see myself getting
that attachment I always I always say
with like or kubert's
nowhere I always say with like writing
with like George Lucas and you know and
these nostalgic things and Michael
painting or turtles if if you're letting
that destroy your childhood you never
had a childhood worth holding on to
if you're really gonna let that kill
your childhood and your long for Chris
fashion I was chained to a radiator and
abused as a child and all I had was cute
if you just shut up please share me that
story that's the truth I dolly that's me
a 20/20 that should have been pics in
the hard hard hard-core drama Oh kid
whose only life was video games but yeah
bad about summed it up there uh yeah not
the worst not even about getting that
angry over but I want to do a kiss a
everybody was asking me to do it a do a
clipless review and B I really did want
to address the anger II was getting cuz
yeah kind of before Fantastic Four phase
it has to first day one but before that
like that was the one which shows like a
death of cinema X shows you when when
you hear that argument about the death
of cinema oh and it's the worst and that
like that was the perfect example of
like how everybody was all over pixels
and it fantastic for came out a couple
weeks later it's like oh yeah and like I
listen the Fantastic Four movie I'm sure
sucks but I I can't we've seen a lot of
shit it's really hard to be like no this
is the worst thing ever
like for one thing I just don't want to
give pixels that much credit like it's
like it's not even good it's not even
good enough to be the worst thing ever
so and plus it just drives people to go
see it when I hear the worst thing ever
yeah I betrayed that's what disappointed
me about pixels I got told oh it's the
worst thing ever and I'm like yeah this
is nothing like this is just mad I
thought I was gonna get like room
quality nonsense here and instead it's
just a blase comedy yeah so um there it
is and we will see you guys in the next
one later